i want to ask you about um anti-aging i
mean do you have an anti-aging protocol
to
longevity to health um like is your
supplement stack that you look at i'm
just curious what your position on that
is
yeah so um
one of the things that i discovered
you know fairly early on looking at all
this stuff was that body composition is
really important for aging
so when you look at the changes that um
you know that someone you know that
someone has when they get old when as
they age
a lot of this
resembles the same changes that you see
in obesity and diabetes
so
they're not necessarily of the same
magnitude if in other words if somebody
stays
lean and fit that they're going to have
fewer of these changes but these changes
do seem to be intrinsic to to aging
people lose muscle that is a big one um
that that is very uh underrated so
if you don't consciously try to keep
muscle then you're going to lose it and
it starts from a very
fairly young age say the age of 30.
it's also a direct correlation if i'm
not mistaken between skeletal muscle
mass like lean skeletal muscle mass and
diseases
i think like alzheimer's dementia like
there's a lot of degenerative diseases
as you get older as a guy that you're
more likely to to get if you don't have
i mean not not bodybuilder size muscle
obviously but like lean skeletal muscle
on your body where i mean i tell guys
look if you can't do
20 push-ups 10 chin ups and skip rope
for a minute or two at like at least
start there like that's a basic
foundational sort of like requirement
for most guys and that should be the
same if you're 30 or 50 or even 60. i
mean you should be able to do something
basic like that at any age so what's the
relevance to the amount of like skeletal
muscle mass when it comes to
minimizing limiting aging you know
degenerative diseases and all that stuff
well so you know skeletal muscle is
uh
[Music]
what one way of looking at it is it's a
metabolic sink so
most of the energy
that that uh you use has to do with
skeletal muscle uh
and i mean unless you were
if you were completely sedentary um
you know a lot of the energy just goes
to you know maintaining your basal
metabolic rate um but
your skeletal muscle uses a lot of
energy it's a sink for for glucose um
and so it is very important in aging and
and the fact that
a man who
gets to the age of 80 can have lost
half the muscle mass he had when he was
20. right so that's a huge amount
and
so one one consequence of this is
that people become
frail
and they become
you know if if this goes of course
we're generally talking here about quite
elderly people but
if you get frail enough then you need
help living you know if you can't get
out of your chair by yourself and this
happens a lot um and then people end up
in nursing homes for for this reason
um but as far as your overall health
there's you know definitely a
correlation with the amount of muscle
you have there's a correlation with
mortality so with people have more
muscle mass they have lower death rates
um so all these things and then
you know regarding these changes that
like i was saying that resemble you know
diabetes or obesity you can fend these
off
um
with
having more muscle mass with doing
strength training
so as far as anti-aging goes i consider
this i consider
strength training to be fundamental
and
the other part of this of the training
with regards to aging
is keeping body fat off is very
important too so
you know there there's um
older people generally have
uh poorer metabolism so this has
actually been looked at
so they they you know uh for example
insulin sensitivity which is really
important they look at these older
people they their insulin sensitivity
is not as good as people who are younger
however
when they control for waist size they
find that there's little difference the
difference is is that these older people
put on body fat put on visceral fat and
if you can keep that off
then your insulin sensitivity is going
to be
uh very nearly that of a younger person
speaking of insulin sensitivity what's
your take on metformin as an as an
anti-aging compound do you take that is
that something that you recommend i i
have taken it from time to time um it's
one of those things that
i can't say that i've noticed anything
uh
you know that that it's done
the
so this is interesting um so metformin
is an anti-diabetic drug and so this
fits in with what i was just saying as
as people age they have these
manifestations of something that
resembles changes towards towards
diabetes and this also
uh so metformin
anti-diabetic drug fights aging so it
has been shown to extend lifespan in lab
animals now the question is in my mind
does metformin do
anything for someone who is already lean
and fit um
you know or is it merely combating
what we
uh
you know are basically our modern food
environment our modern sedentary
environment you know what is it doing my
i've thought about this a lot read about
it a lot my view is yes it may it may do
something for older people who are
already lean and fit and doing
everything it it
it obviously like with so many things it
does more for people who need it more
um
so
yeah so you know there's going to be a
clinical trial of metformin um
to
to uh
to see to look at its anti-aging effects
in humans
um
you know one thing about metformin is
it's dirt cheap um you you know you can
pick it up for like five or six cents a
tablet and so and it's generic so
there's very little incentive
for people to study it
um you know in human beings uh most most
of the work has been been done in
animals but of course a lot of people
take metformin it's the most prescribed
anti-diabetic drug so they've looked at
a lot of these
uh populations too
what about um
other compounds i was watching this uh
conversation with uh dr david sinclair i
think is his name do you know who he is
yes i do um hubermann they were talking
about anti-aging and longevity and i
think the two compounds that stood out
um were resveral i i don't know if i'm
pronouncing that right
yeah that's it and uh something else
called nmn which um studied in lab
animals apparently extended their lives
like by something like thirty percent
like lab mice like live two like two
years max is pretty standard they've
seen them live live to like four or five
years
um
what do you know about that stuff yeah
yeah so
so this this is interesting too um from
the same point of view as metformin so
nmn is
nicotinamide mononucleotide there's
another similar compound they're not the
same but nicotinamide riboside
these are both forms of vitamin b3
nicotinamide or niacin
and and so nicotinamide is not exactly
the same as niacin but they are both
forms of vitamin b3
um
so
it's
and and they make a certain compound nad
plus that is important in metabolism
that declines with age so this this is
the basis i tried taking nr nicotinamide
riboside i tried taking it for a month
didn't notice anything and it was quite
expensive so i stopped
there's also some evidence and the these
these people like david sinclair or
charles brenner is another one would
might dispute me on this but there's
also some evidence that just taking
plain old vitamin b3 nicotinamide will
do the same thing
as far as raising your levels of nad
plus
the other thing is
that if you look at what happens when
people go on a low carb diet or or start
exercising
with intensity is nad plus levels also
go up so
just like with metformin what we're
looking at here is this really doing is
is this going to help lean and healthy
people who are already lean and healthy
who are old like nmn is it going to do
that
you know i i don't know i have to be
agnostic on it i'm i'm not taking it um
and i feel like my diet and exercise is
probably keeping my nad plus levels just
as high as they can possibly be
and and if you take vitamin b3
nicotinamide plain old see
these
supplements like an mn or nr
um i i don't want to attribute uh
nefarious motives to people but one
reason that people are looking into
these kind of things is because they can
make money at it right okay expensive
supplement sure
sure and so there's nothing wrong with
making money but
if taking plain old
vitamin b3 which is really really cheap
it works the same obviously they're not
interested in looking at that there's a
very similar one
um a recent article it was published on
this new uh supplement called rejuvent
and rejuvent
so they they've tested it in animals and
it extends lifespan and they did this
study on humans where they looked at
markers
epigenetic markers of aging and it made
made these markers go down so they were
epigenetically younger from taking
rejuven well what is rejuven rejuven
is
uh a compound called
alpha-ketoglutarate
and some vitamins
so alpha-ketoglutarate alpha
ketoglutarate you can go on amazon and
buy a big bag like this from bulk
supplements for you know 20 bucks
right so but who's going to make money
at that so they have to put it into a
proprietary
formula
uh and and so they can say it's got
alpha chemotherapy and some vitamins
special vitamins and yeah give it a name
and then test it on humans and then they
can say see look this study shows
rejuvent
um you know and then sell it for 50 100
bucks a month whatever
um
so this dynamic is is going on a lot
rapamycin is another one a very
promising anti-aging drug and it's more
expensive than
metformin or
or rejuvenators or nmn or anything like
that however it's still generic
nobody has an incentive you know to
really study it in humans
as far as resveratrol resveratrol is
interesting
i took it for a long time i'm no longer
taking it um
resveratrol has has never been shown to
extend lifespan in
in mammals right so it's extended
lifespan in some lower or so-called
lower organisms like worms and flies
but um they give it to mice it help it
helps
um
protect against the effects of a
high-fat high sugar diet and mice so
actually so
just to correct that i think he said
that if you take it daily
it doesn't have much of an effect but he
said that if you take it every other day
then that's when they saw the longevity
effects on the lab mice
um well i don't know about that the the
one
the one big study that came out
maybe 15 years ago that
uh or 10 years ago that maybe
that seemed to
result in a lot of people losing
interest in resveratrol was that it did
not extend lifespan of these mice that
it did protect against the high fat high
sugar diet but um so this is another
thing
similar
like i was just talking about with
metformin or nad plus it's like what is
this doing is this protecting against
a horrible food environment a horrible
sedentary environment or is it really
fighting aging
disentangling these things
is difficult um because everybody's
living in this environment
and pretty much you know i mean over 80
percent of the u.s population is either
overweight or obese
and it gets worse
it's like about 80 now it it is yes and
and you know a lot of the rest of them
are skinny fat so
um
yeah yeah i mean
only
only uh one study showed that only 12
percent of the us population was
metabolically healthy
that's horrible yeah and they're
cramming all these jabs down everybody's
throats and you don't do these you don't
get to go anywhere but they never say
anything about losing body fat or eating
properly that that's right that's right
this this is something that
i've talked about quite a bit over the
last year and a half i mean
uh obesity diabetes
those two
along with
pure chronic logical age are the biggest
risk factors for having severe covet
disease and also vitamin d deficiency
uh i mean vitamin d
um
you know you can
again it's dirt cheap
just like some of these things we were
talking about and nobody's mentioning it
um i got to ask you though like
you know be specific because i mean you
look good for your agent
it says on your twitter you're 66 and
your skin doesn't look 66 i mean people
might even argue watching this like i'm
in my late 40s that
we look the same practically as far as
the skin condition
like what do you take as far as
supplements for anti-aging for yourself
is there anything that you rely on at
this point or is it just you know
lots of water good diet and exercise and
sunlight i i do take some supplements um
as far as as far as my skin i guess
uh
you know genetics again probably has
something to do with it my my mother had
nice skin into a very old age
um
but i do take some supplements i do
credit
diet and exercise
with a lot of
um you know what i look like and how i
feel is certainly the most important
thing
people
people and i'll tell you about the
supplements but
people want to
um
you know there's this idea of adding
something versus subtracting something
so you know people want a magic pill
um something to take that's going to
um
you know um
negate their bad habits or you know
anything else they're doing
um rather than
you know subtracting what
they're they're doing that that isn't
helping them so um
i mean this phenomenon is not just in
the world of supplements or something
like that i mean every doctor deals with
it right so you know somebody somebody
uh
you know goes to the doctor and the
doctor says well you've got diabetes um
and and the patient says okay doc you
know give me a pill
rather than you know change the
conditions that led them into diabetes
so this this is just
you know everywhere that's what that's
what people are like
so anyway yes diet and exercise um i
take
uh i take baby aspirin
um and i have been for quite a while so
there there's some good evidence for
that if you talk about it online there's
all kinds of controversy but i've
decided that it's good for me
um
and and also by the way with baby
aspirin let me just add
there can be serious side effects so i
you know i don't tell people yeah go go
ahead take take aspirin you know it's
something that um basically should be
talked over with a doctor and decide
whether that's a good thing to do
um
i take magnesium so magnesium is really
important and this is a supplement that
probably most everybody could use is
there any option that you like the
innate chili i i take uh magnesium
citrate um okay there are some other
good ones like glycinate is a good one i
think uh theonate's the one that that
that bridges the blood brain barrier
like that's better for your brain
especially for sleep too i i believe
that is correct yes um
so vast numbers of people in the united
states are magnesium deficient um and
this has to do with a lot of things like
for example monocrop agriculture has
leach magnesium out of the soil
and and so they're not getting as much
in their in their diets people used to
get a lot of magnesium from drinking
hard water which they don't anymore
and um then other things like caffeine
and alcohol can deplete magnesium so
there's all kinds of reasons so i do
take magnesium and i feel that most
people would would benefit from it
what else i take
i take vitamin d
so this is something i've been doing a
long time i take 5000 iu's of vitamin d
every day except maybe you know in the
summer when i'm getting some sun
um so sunscreen when you're outside in
the sun or no no no i don't uh i don't
use sunscreen most of the sunscreens out
there are basically toxic brews
um and there are some that are that are
better you can find them but the average
zinc-based ones
yes exactly exactly and oddly enough um
what is her name
gwyneth paltrow i think has some
sunscreens that are like pretty good um
if if i'm remembering correctly but
they're you know
you got to seek those out if you just
get regular sunscreen it's no you don't
want to do that best sunscreen
is
shades clothing and hat
or suntan yeah yeah or
suntan but i mean people people say well
you know people ask me well i'm going to
be out in the sun all day long what do i
do i say well put on a long sleeve shirt
wear a hat you know
so um yeah so vitamin d
um i take taurine which is an amino acid
which has some good anti-aging effects
um
i
over the last what are the anti-aging
effects of taurine because i understood
it just to be a cell volume volumizer or
like an energy source um it it functions
as an antioxidant in much the same way
as glutathione does or somewhat the same
way yes and so we
um
our cells have the ability to make
taurine and we get some in our diet but
it does
deplete with age
um so it that that's something that i've
i've found useful for me
here's another one citrulline this this
is a really interesting supplement
um
citrulline promotes
the the production of nitric oxide in
blood vessels so this is very important
nitric oxide um
allows
uh blood vessels to expand uh to dilate
and so this is this is a really
important thing there's
good evidence that all this the dilation
and so on or lack of it is involved in
coronary artery disease and so on so
citrulline um helps promote nitric oxide
uh production
um so that's a good one and um it's good
for jib pumps it's also good for bedroom
pumps too
yep exactly exactly
exactly that's what it does yeah that
you can you can find uh citrulline added
to you know previously about supplements
supplement bag off amazon that's the one
that i've bought in the past exactly
yeah right right so um
you know that about covers it
okay that's interesting
you